nun aber die Schockmeldung der Woche ein
Viertel der Deutschen Viertklässler kann
laut iglu-studien nicht richtig lesen
ja und die anderen drei Viertel wissen
nicht was ein Viertel ist ja gut die
Meldung kann natürlich richtig Wellen
geschlagen
hat keine Sau interessiert hat kaum
einer drüber geschrieben nein medial
funktionieren ganz andere Sachen bei uns
riesen Shitstorm gigantischer Shitstorm
weil die Münchner Stadtbibliothek im
Rahmen der Pride week zu einer
Veranstaltung lädt bei der Drag Queens
Kindern was Vorlesen ja gut jetzt frage
ich mich warum ist das so ein Aufreger
dann kann doch jeder selber entscheiden
als Elternteil ob er damit seinen
Kindern hingeht oder nicht denkt man
aber in Bayern ist halt Wahlkampf
wenn ich dann sehe dass der der dort
vorlesen soll sich Erik große Klitoris
nennt dann ist mir fast egal ob er dann
über diese Dinge redet oder ob er nur
von Buben im Prinzessinnen Kleidern und
so weiter redet ja also ich muss sagen
spätestens wenn Hubert Aiwanger das Wort
Klitoris sagt
geht die letzte Erotik zum Teufel das
ist ja wirklich ja
tatsächlich nennt sich einer der beiden
lesungskünstler King Eric big Klit
da kommt ist letztlich auch nur ein
Körperteil wirklich so ungeplant ist
natürlich weder eine Travestieshow noch
geht es da irgendwie um Sex big Klit hat
sogar und das finde ich pervers
Sozialarbeit studiert es gibt
verschiedene Bücher die sind auch vom
Jugendamt geprüft gibt es einen
Jugendschutz der wird wirklich aufs
Alter drauf geschaut das wird so
durchgeprüft wie man sonst in Schulen
und überall nur wünschen kann
durchgeprüft die lesen aus
altersgerechten Bilderbücher zu Themen
wie Rollenwechsel und Verkleidung im
Grunde ein ja klettererisches Quartett
trotzdem kriegen sich einfacher und Co
gar nicht wieder ein die CSU-Fraktion
Bogenhausen wollte eine
Dringlichkeitssitzung und die Lesung zu
unterbinden klar eine Veranstaltung mit
der Botschaft jeder ist okay so wie er
ist wo kann man denn dahin ich finde am
besten überarbeiten wir jetzt auch die
Kinderbuch Klassiker oder der super
diverse bunte Regenbogenfisch heißt ab
sofort wieder die normale Makrele
die kleine Hexe wird verbrannt ne
logisch weil sie lesbisch ist unten eine
Hexe und Rotkäppchen erschießt den bösen
Wolf weil er Frauen Kleider trägt die
Sau
aber jetzt mal wirklich warum genau
sollte man solche Lesungen verbieten
dürfen Männer und Frauen nur bestimmte
Klamotten tragen wenn sie was vorlesen
müssen Kinder die Polizei rufen wenn der
Papa beim vorlesene Schürze trägt ja das
ist doppelt schlimm weil dann hat die
Mutter ja nicht gekocht ne ja war sie
etwa arbeiten
in Hosen
geht gar nicht viele Leute die vor der
Sexualisierung von Kindern waren finden
sowas hier auf der Münchner Wiesen
übrigens völlig okay
Motive dieser Fahrgeschäfte und Buden
klischeehafte Eingeborene ein schwarzer
der unter den Rock einer Frau schaut
nackte Brüste da geht es um Spaß haben
und nicht darum die Politiker korrekten
es auf der Wiesen dann auch noch
möglichst breit auszutreten ja genau das
eine ist halt
Traditionspflege für normale das andere
perverser Schweinkram
ne so Martin
CSU-Generalsekretär hat zur drag-lesung
getwittert Zitat vierjährige sollten mit
Bauklötzen oder mit Knete spielen und
nicht mit Walker frühsexualisierung
indoktriniert werden ja komisch neulich
beim csuperti-tag war der Knete
Fetischist hier noch strikt
gegenverbotskultur gegen kenzel culture
stattdessen jeder wieder mal kruzifik
noch eins jeder Mensch ist wertvoll in
seiner Einzigartigkeit wir gehen vom
Individuum aus wir kennen auch die
Unterschiedlichkeit der Menschen an wir
glauben an die Einzigartigkeit des
Menschen an seine individuelle
Schaffenskraft wir schreiben nicht vor
sondern wir ermöglichen blablablablabla
hm ja wir als CSU schreiben keinem was
vor
der ein eindeutiges Geschlecht hat
Fleisch ist und nicht gendert
frühsexualisierung ist ein Kampfbegriff
den fundamentale Christen verwenden um
Stimmung zu machen gegen jede Art von
Sexualkunde gegen jeder Art von
Sexualkunde trotzdem
steht der Begriff sogar im
Parteiprogramm der CSU da überrascht das
einen auch gar nicht mehr dass eine
csu-reisegruppe rund um an die scheuer
gerade
dass das schon Lacher ist also das ist
eine Reisegruppe rund um an die Steuer
gerade ronde Säntis besucht hat also den
Ultra konservativen von Florida ja die
Krone der anti-wogbewegung den Erfinder
des don't say gay gesetztes Unterricht
über Geschlechtsidentität und Sexualität
ist in Florida an öffentlichen Schulen
in allen Altersstufen verboten
nicht zu vergessen dass in Florida eine
Schulleiterin den Hund nehmen musste
weil sie ihren Schülern und verhüllt
mitgeladenlos David zumutete sofort
Pornografie ja pfui meine gut viele
Amerikaner haben ja noch nie einen Penis
gesehen
weil der Bauch dazwischen ist
das sagt der richtige so ich frage mich
mal wer wer holt sich eine Audienz bei
Disentis und weiß der Run überhaupt wer
in der Besuch hat hey Ron be careful the
Bavarians are all perverse hier Tour auf
seinem at the Fetisch Messe in the very
gay city of Cologne
love to suck Penis shaded white sausages
it's Casting this is Sportunterricht
School und hier ist der King sorry Queen
Markus big Maus Söder
ja
ja Freunde ihr ihr freut euch aber
solche Bilder hier werden unter dezentes
ein Kündigungsgrund ist Florida trotzdem
Vorbild für Bayern vielleicht erste
Modellprojekte laufen schon
Dennis knossalla unterrichtet Mathematik
am Hubert aiwanger-gymnasium in Passau
also Leute zwei Vektoren werden addiert
indem jede Komponente einzeln addiert
wird aber wie berechnet man die Länge
eines Vektors aufmerksam begleitet von
dieser Elternvertreterin ja klar fühlt
man sich da am Anfang ein bisschen
kontrolliert aber es ging eben nicht
anders ich habe die Kinder in meinem
Unterricht wohl jahrelang ohne es zu
wollen total sexualisiert und das sind
Mathe weiß gar nicht wie ich das
geschafft habe also wir berechnen das
Volumen eines Zylinders und zwar dieses
Zylinders das heißt Grundfläche R
quadratie mal Höhe 25 cm ich verteile
mal ein paar damit ihr ein Gefühl dafür
kriegt er war gar nicht bewusst was ich
da Anrichte
am Ende des Halbjahres war in dem Kurs
nur noch ein einziger Junge
heterosexuell den haben sie dann brutal
gemobbt juhu
du bist hetero du bist
naja und deswegen stimme ich mich jetzt
immer ab mit der Frau Gruber hier
mit 150 km/h aus Darmstadt aus
nicht aus Darmstadt aus Bückeburg
auch nicht gütersloh
nach Aachen ein er kommt aber viel zu
früh
okay
dann wünsche ich euch ein schönes
Wochenende ja Tschüss
[Applaus]
wir stellen fest
wir merken nicht nur die USA auch
Deutschland verliebt sich immer mehr in
solche Kulturkämpfe nächstes aktuelles
Beispiel das Theater um eine Kita in
Hessen die es gewagt hat das Basteln von
Mutter und vatertagsgeschenken abzusagen
ja Geschenke basteln ist da
illegal ja es ist so Hintergrund also
zum Hintergrund die Kita-Leitung wollte
die Kinder etwa von allein erziehenden
nicht unnötig ausgrenzt inzwischen hat
der Kindergarten klargestellt man werde
sich weiterhin für das christliche
Familienbild einsetzen gleichzeitig
andere Lebensrealitäten nicht
ausschließen klingt erstmal vernünftig
trotzdem hat sie werden sich glauben
Hubert Aiwanger direkt getwittert
Achtung wer den Muttertag in Frage
stellt kommt mit seinem Leben nicht klar
aha dann kommt jetzt sieht man sich mal
ja und der stellt den Muttertag in Frage
wischmeyers Wirkung der Bekloppten und
bescheuerten
erst Muttertag und gestern Vatertag die
Einschläge kommen näher dabei dachte ich
die gibt's gar nicht mehr Vater und
Mutter wären längst in den
Patchworkfamilien aufgegangen wozu dann
noch ein jeweiliger Gedenktag für
besaufende und entbindende das erreicht
doch ein gemeinsamer Termin und welche
moderne Mutter möchte schon sowas hier
und über ein selbstgemaltes Bild freut
sich die Mutti sicher ebenso wie über
das Gedicht
[Musik]
dein blödes Gedicht das ist doch ein
Witz und Mama jetzt endlich einen Aperol
spritzt wie wäre es denn mal mit
vernünftigen Geschenken ein Sky-Abo oder
so ja aber das ist so teuer für heute
arbeiten niemand will Bastelkram oder
selbstgemalte Bilder weil die Scheiße
sind da stimmt nichts wer soll das sein
die Geissens nach einem Nuklearangriff
und um das Maß der Demütigung voll zu
machen kriegt Mutti das Frühstück im
Bett serviert als ob es mit ihr zu Ende
ginge ich sage Weg mit dem Quatsch
allein schon um Tilman Kuban von der CDU
zu ärgern der hatte wegen des
kita-bastelverbots in Hessen getwittert
dem Wahnsinn sind keine Grenzen mehr
gesetzt irgendwie finde ich es ziemlich
cool wenn man Kindern beibringt seiner
Mutter Einfach mal DANKE zu sagen für
Ihren mega-einsatz Tag für Tag was für
ein Schleimer und dann hat der tumbe
Tillmann in selben Tweet noch die
Adresse der Kita veröffentlicht die
seitdem mit Hass zugekügelt wird den Typ
kannte ich bisher nur aus einem
waldsport oder wie so ein lungenkrankes
Murmeltier eine Abraumhalde hochkraxelt
für Deutschland wahrscheinlich
Vorschlag lasst uns den antiquierten
heldentag für Gebärende beerdigen und
Vatertag gleich mit Christi Himmelfahrt
was soll das sein wer fährt da wohin
wahrscheinlich Jesus ins Homeoffice dann
Feiertag der dem Individualverkehr
huldigt ist eh aus der Zeit gefallen
denn Jesus hat kein deutschlandticket
also weg mit Himmelfahrt und wo wir
schon mal dabei sind auch mit
Pfingstmontag karfriday und happy
Kadaver day bloß die ganzen erfundenen
zusatzfeiertage der faulen Bayern
natürlich Maria Besäufnis peterchens
Mondfahrt keine Ahnung am besten wir
schmeißen den ganzen Mist sandbrücken
Tage zusammen und feiern eine Woche
Bahnstreik plus wer die Demo kleben uns
auf der eigenen Terrasse fest und
vergessen für einen kurzen glückseligen
Moment in welchem Land wir leben
[Musik]
Buch der Bekloppten und bescheuerten
[Applaus]
[Musik]
oh Gott für die